20 year old American Ben Shelton's run
at the US Open has everyone talking more
specifically everyone is talking about
this so what's the deal with this phone
celebration it's definitely one of the
coolest celebrations we've seen in
tennis inspired by his good friend and
track and field star Grant Holloway
Shelton says he does his phone
celebration to indicate that he is 100
dialed it and believe me he's dialed in
he's the youngest American to reach the
semi since Andy Roddick and he set the
record for the fastest serve at this Us
open at 149 miles per hour which is
shocking considering that he started
playing at a much later age than usual
it was because when he was younger he
dreamed of playing a completely
different sport see his father played
professional tennis in the 90s and his
mother played Juniors but Ben wanted to
be a quarterback he didn't start
actually playing competitive tennis
matches until he was 11. he eventually
decided to commit to Florida where his
dad was the head coach of the tennis
team and he got good quickly he won the
NCAA men's singles championship in 2021
before turning professional and
continuing his degree online and given
his success at the US Open he has
definitely made the right choice